هذه صور منها تاي من تركيا
ايضا حاله من الخوف والهلع ترافق الناس في
المخيمات الذين يعني اوت الناس بعد
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا في السادس من هذا
الشهر
نتابع هذه الصور منها نستمع الى صوت
الطبيعي
الله اكبر
هذه سيارات الشرطه ايضا هناك
وحسب
مشهد ايضا بانه هناك انقطاع للتيار
الكهربائي وبعد شهود العيان تحدث بان هناك
انقطاع للانترنت وانقطاع للتيار الكهربائي
حقيقه مشاهد يعني
قاسيه لهؤلاء الناس الذين لم
يستطيعوا ان يرسم ما حصل منذ اسبوعين
وما زالوا ينمنمون جراحههم من جراء
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا في الاسبوع منذ
اسبوعين نتابع ايضا هذه المسنه التي يبدو
تعاني من ضيق في النفس يحاولون اسعافها
حقيقه يعني منذ اسبوعين ونحن نتابع هذه
المشاهد التي تكسر القلب للاطفال المسنين
للشباب الذين يعيشون هذا الخوف الذي لا
يتوقف جراء هذه الزلازل والهلزات الارضيه
التي تضرب تركيا وتضرب ايضا سوريا شمال
سوريا واليوم الهزه الارضيه شعر بها اهل
لبنان وايضا فلسطين